hey folks so a lot of people are going
to be playing Fallout 4 this week and a
lot of people who have never played a
fallout before folks who break like for
bobby pins on every lock use the laser
musket for the entire game
and still don't know what jet is for but
if you're like me and you've been around
the waistline or two then fallout 4 has
a difficulty mode that you may want to
take a look at it's called survival mode
last week I sacrifice myself to playing
it for 10 hours to give you guys a heads
up on just how hard it is and whether or
not it's worth your time may it serve
you well in battle ok first things first
this really shouldn't be called survival
mode because the normal aspects of what
we've come to expect of a survival mode
in 2015 are not here in fact gone are
many of the additions that obsidian
added to the franchise in new vegas is
hardcore mode you may remember that in
hardcore mode you needed to sustain
yourself with food and water while
making sure you got enough sleep you had
to use special items to restore limbs
and companions could be killed in combat
well none of this isn't fallout 4
survival mode survival mode simply does
some things to make the game a lot
harder first of all you're gonna take a
lot more damage and give it less this is
mostly going to be a problem when you
encounter packs of enemies in Fallout 4
feral ghouls and mole rats frequently
attack in packs and often unexpectedly
ensuring you have enough ap to that's
when they swarm you is important but so
too are bullets fallout players are used
to having a scratch around for
ammunition but even abundant ammo like
ten millimeter rounds could be hard to
come by in survival mode not just
because the game is hard but because
you're not going to be spending as much
time getting into potentially lucrative
firefights it takes bullets to get
bullets and while a normal difficulty
fallout 4 presents you with firefights
which can often prove worthwhile
engagements in survival mode can be so
taxing that you find yourself avoiding
them and this is basically the loop of
survival mode what is essentially an
exercise in decision-making you can't
afford not to get into battles which may
net you better gear and weaponry but in
survival mode you have to take your
battles and make sure you're damn
prepared for them invest in stimpacks
use cams and battle both ed and psycho
for taking hits and jet for giving it
try and ensure you have one decent
long-range weapon invest in perks to
complement rifles general endurance or
better still charisma so you can avoid
battles completely the name of the game
is resisting damage because stimpaks are
going to take longer
here you in survival mode Oh in case
that wasn't enough and survival mode the
frequency by which you encounter
legendary enemies is also increased
these are tougher than normal enemies
which each have a unique piece of gear
these guys are bullet sponges that may
not be worth the butter don't be afraid
to walk away and live to fight another
day there's no doubt about it life in
survival mode is tough and I certainly
wouldn't recommend it for a first
run-through of the game because a lot of
the subtle mechanics and rules of this
world are going to be fresh to you when
you first get out of the vault also some
of the main quest boss fights become
arduous unless you've been really taking
care of your progression but for those
of you who are looking to play the game
multiple times it's an added challenge
for those of you looking to have a more
testing second or third playthrough for
more fallout 4 tips make sure you check
out game spots fallout for a show and in
the meantime for all your wasteland
needs stay tuned to games.com
you